Less complexity, but it is still wellness and tanning is still home. We have eight stores and just right in the way of 11.
I wouldn't be able to do it without friends in the industry and UBlock, so I'm really happy to be here and help in any way.
Hi, I'm Doug McNabb,
the owner of FabuTan. We've got locations across the country. We've been doing this since I was 20 years old, which is seven years ago.
ago. Now it's 40 years now that I've been in the business. I think Nick was probably
in the maybe seven, six years old equipment when I started. But we do, we've been doing
Red Light for well over 10, 12 years across the country. We do one base level UV bed exploring
with some other ways to run the business. I did leave 5, 10, 6 or 7 years, came back
a couple years ago. I'm really excited, really re-energized with the, with this move towards
I do some coaching consulting for some U.S.-based franchisors who really embrace the direction
of wellness.
Saj Heights is a U.S.-based franchisor.
They're moving very aggressively to about 40% of their rooms are wellness, touchless
services.
As Mike mentioned, touchless, that is the buzzword in that industry and at their company.
I think the primary thing that I love about touchless, just like we've loved about our
business for so long is that we don't have increased labor associated with
every dollar of service which is very traditional in old-school wellness so
share whatever I can with you and thanks for having me.
My next question is actually going to be for Lisa.
We all know your wellness brand is something new, but Tanning has always supported confidence and self-care.
How do you communicate the message that Tanning itself is wellness for both your clients and your
is that was really important to me.
You heard Nick talk about the very dear friend
that he has since tanning is wellness.
So we were joking around yesterday,
but to me, tanning is wellness.
So when I got into tanning, I was also 20,
and it just came from a difference of both myself
and my husband were told to tan by our doctors.
So we have always thought of the wellness side of tanning
have always been important to us so that is uh that's always been so when we went into the wellness
side of our industries it didn't make a different change it was actually just kind of figuring out
how to name it differently we're huge into membership because that's how we think wellness
can grow. Yeah, I think everything, in every package you have, if we call it wellness,
tanning is a part of it, because of tanning.
We are dabbling in wellness, like everyone has been saying. The hardest thing for us
was transitioning the verbiage for our staff members, as well as all of our marketing,
all of the stuff that we had to really sit down and say, okay, this is how we're going
going to do it we're going to train our staff to say it this way it's not going to be unlimited
it's not going to be tanning it's about a sun experience a sun session versus tanning um yes
it's still in our name yes it's still out there but most of the stuff that we're leaning towards
is the wellness side of things and how it makes you feel the feeling so when you're marketing to
clients you're marketing to a client you want you're always looking at that one client and
And that client has to get something from, like Mike was saying earlier, they want to buy it again.
They want to spend money again to come and see you.
So it's super important that when you're looking at adding wellness or expanding your wellness,
that your main core is structured in a way that when you add to it, it doesn't take away from it.
So I'm a firm believer in that I was a tanning salon first.
So my main core is tanning.
But I also want to be able to add value to my clients.
So that's where we're heading with our wellness is that we're value-driven, but I am still, my core and my gaps don't create bigger gaps, they create smaller gaps.
So if I'm like, I need to put something in here because I'm not generating enough return on investment, that's when I'm looking at it.
Because we live in a world of sales, if you're not selling, we're not in this room.
So it's super important that the wellness that you're putting in is added to what you already have.
So you have to have a good foundation in what your core value is.
100%. I just want to touch on a couple things that Tali said there.
First thing is when it comes to incorporating wellness into your marketing and your entire strategy,
I want you to go into your salon and look at it with a lens and look around.
You know, we've got salons all across America that are like, you know what, I'm changing.
Tanning is wellness, so I'm going to be Tom's tanning and wellness.
And you walk up to Tom's tanning and you still have this great big sign that says,
cotton lamps right so your decor your aesthetic so take a look at your salon and try to look at
it with the projection body to say just because you changed your name doesn't mean that makes you
that wellness center i want you to look at everything and really embrace that
the other thing that sally mentioned as well is when it comes to adding that wellness we know
We know that sun is wellness and we also know that the number one reason why people are coming in to see us and the core of our business is UV tanning.
Make sure you have your UV tanning game up here, right?
Get your house in order before you add to it.
That was a really good comment. Thank you.
Yes, I was going to touch on your tanning beds have to be your, they've got to be the
best of the best to have that happen.
You can't bring in a new flashy bit of wellness, but you have a bed from 20 years ago.
What I was going to add is you'll think, okay, my core is tanning.
What the most exciting thing for us has been seeing clients that I maybe haven't seen in 10 or 15 years because they decided they were no longer a tanner, right? So they came back to the wellness center side with absolutely no intentions of ever touching a tanning bed again.
But of course our packages all have the tanning in them. UV light therapy is incredibly important for you.
And every, I would say 100% of the time, but I'm sure I'm a little bit off on that, is the favorite thing that client is doing is tanning.
I've just given them permission to be okay with what they're doing in their 40s and 50s and 60s that they thought they weren't okay with before.
because the media is telling them that it's not okay so you've got to have the
best tanning because your wellness is actually going to bring in more
well I think we've always been doing wellness I mean even if you take out
everything that the services we offer people come in most people the color
you receive is a byproduct of coming in and relaxing many people come in they
want to relax they want that experience so we've always been that experience and
I think all we're doing is shifting the focus but again to most people's point
up here is that if you just change your name and put a wellness behind it but
don't change anything don't do anything and don't invest in your business change
your marketing change the way you present yourself from the front desk
staff to the way your salon is decorated to your marketing to your
social media you're you're not doing anybody a service because at this point the wave
we're the wave is is it's not gone but certainly we're not early in the stage and we were riding
at a certain rate we're more than halfway past the life and they're actually a new word they're
starting to get into now is longevity longevity centers when we offer longevity so you can almost
see the next wave coming so you just make sure that you change your operations to match what
you're trying to sell to catch the next batch of customers and that comes through equipment
i mean all of our favorite beds i think everybody here will say is a 1050. i don't know if anybody's
got one they're they're they're 15 years old now they're 12 years old and so as we start to
look at new equipment like the vitality and the essence and all these new beds they're expensive
and it's very painful very painful um just a quick story is we were looking to get one last year
and Sivak, the brains of the operation,
and Namel oftentimes was convincing me to get a vitality.
The payments were very expensive.
And he said, I guarantee you we'll make the payments.
In about eight months, we had that bid approved.
And that was quite a surprise.
But it crushes.
That's what people are looking for.
People are coming back to UV
as long as they don't associate with that 80s style of tanning.
You just need to switch it up and stay modern.
and the funds will follow. As nervous and mind-wracking as it may be, the funds will come.
She does a very, very good job of doing that. Rachel, do you have anything to add to the wellness content?
I threw that out already.
It's Rachel here, I follow her on socials because she does such a great job, so I just thought I would share that.
Oh yeah, I can share that. Marketing our stuff is hard. You can ask your staff, I don't have to say Lisa's incredible at it,
their staff are so cute and funny, and social media trends change so fast.
I can really maybe really in that sense that it's you're running a whole business you're designing everything you're you're tired
So what I did was I hired a company that takes video. We actually hired a modeling agency and
Negotiated a rate with them and we just had it booked every two weeks that we were doing photo photo and video shoots
We said we want three reels
We want a bunch of story content and we want 20 photos and they have to be these and then
managing the photo shoots actually worked me back to like what are we
talking about for the next month what was relevant last year at this time I'm
not as cute and funny as Lisa is at her stuff and I have to say I kind of laid off in the
last month I found kind of radio silent and sometimes I think that just happens
I used to be really hard on myself about social media and you know kind of have
have some guilt that I wasn't posting the glossy cool stuff.
Maybe recalibrating right now, trying to understand trends
and myself as a consumer, what speaks to me,
and taking advice.
I would say for 2026, because it's nice to ask,
what have I done in the past?
But you probably want to know what leaders are going to do
over the next six months.
And so I would share what I'm looking at
when I leave next week.
I'm in the middle of rebuilding a studio.
I have blood and it has been a nightmare,
but it will be amazing and what I'm looking forward to doing in the next six
weeks is testimonials you know and Mike said something last night to me where he
said are you attending salon with wellness or you a wellness salon that
has tanning in it and I'm sitting in that right now and I need to really
decide that but what gets me at it like what makes me work so hard at this is my
client stories and so I'd like to share them on social media over the next bit
and be a bit less flashy and fancy and more like, you know, like, why do you come to Duke-Mills and Rural?
I'd like to do more of that.
Can I ask a question?
Can we have that talk?
I'll be quick.
I do my fair share of talking.
I'll be very quick.
The question that we all have is something you touched on is you had somebody come in
and shoot videos and do pictures, and I think for a lot of us in this room, it's very tough
to spend money on something that I will say is not a normal employee.
It's not something we would normally have.
We might pay a company to go and do something, but to actually hire a videographer, hire
a photographer, set that up, did you find that you got a return on investment?
Was that worth it?
And if we were nervous about it, and we didn't want to spend money, and I'm speaking for myself here,
I think a lot of people in the room do not spend on that.
Do you find that that was worth it, or you could just have the content yourself through your staff?
A thousand percent worth it.
I'll tell you, even dollars and cents, what I spent.
So I found a company, I went through a ton of media companies.
I put them on a retainer, $2,000 a month.
we agreed to two shoots a month which took us about an hour and a half to two
hours I then called the modeling agency I wanted and I said I want to spend 350
on a model for two hours of work interesting working with the modeling
agency they would not let their models get spray tans and that sucked so now
when we phone because I put them in all the video and they're white as hell and
And I'm like, I'm going to do a spray tan on them.
The models want the spray tan.
So what I would do now, when you do find out what model you've chosen,
they'll give you their Instagram handle.
I would DM them before they come and be like,
can you come get a spray tan tomorrow night?
But don't tell your booking agent you're coming to get a spray tan.
So yeah, so for $2,800 a month, I would end up with six reels,
a bunch of cut or new and floor.
You want that B-roll.
You want as much like I was told by someone and then they did a bunch of videos of a truck and they were like you want the videos of like you know when you open the door and all the like little things you don't think are important and so a lot of b-roll and then specific photos if you had photos coming out or like lotions coming out or products or a new employee or even we did some of the girls headshots.
You know, I realized I hadn't had a headshot in a while.
I was like, let's just do one of those.
Like, all of a sudden, once you have it and we had it set up for a month, you think about so much stuff.
And for $2,800, we use it in our onboardings to show our staff.
Like, here's our staff having fun.
And it kind of reflected the whole brand and made everybody else feel good about it instead of it shot with the camera.
And the views you're getting and the response you feel is worth $2,800.
So it's interesting in that.
I do feel like reposting already been shot glossy photos get lower engagement
that is just a fact if you were to take a story in Instagram it like live you
would get 1,200 watchers if I posted something that I had already done I
think it 300 400 as soon as you upload stuff like that but what it did was it
just if somebody lands on your page at 4 o'clock in the morning and they're
doom scrolling and they see all that glossiness they just get your brand your
staff it reflects them and they feel like it's it's good so it wasn't always
in views was the the worth it to me and sometimes I can feel defeated you're
like I did all that work and I got 300 views and but you get off that and be
like if I land on Instagram does my brand reflect something I'm really proud of
my staff are proud of and then my clients are like this is the place I go
to you know and then they they do say Instagram now is you want you want
bingeable content and Lisa has that. We went on yours, we went to your next one,
your next one, and we're laughing and that's what you need is like you know
your next one, next one, next one, you're only as good as your last I would say six weeks of posts, so yes.
You want to jump to another question, Lane?
I am not.
When it comes to incentives, what incentives and strategies have been the most effective
in motivating your staff, whether financially, culturally, which is really important, and
we'll talk about that a little bit later, or through growth opportunities, and how have
these incentives evolved your business?
I think you have to have staff that are highly incentivized.
and the driving factor is what is the focus for that time period what do you
want focused on understanding the lifetime value of your customer and Mike
had posted as one of the KPIs key performance indicators it's absolutely
imperative that you know what a customer is worth to you over a lifetime and even
over the next 12 months and then to structure your incentives accordingly
we're all fortunate enough majority of our services don't have labor costs so
we have a high margin product that you know get out of $100 for probably
to keep the $85 of it as a gross profit and so if you have a membership for
instance a high incentive to sign up that member upfront is worthwhile
because if you know that you're going to get 16.8 months of that membership at
$69 then you could afford to give a whole bunch upfront knowing that with
that $69 comes product all sorts of other sales other opportunities because
they're a member maybe there's other services that they're going to try so I
So I think managing the business with KPIs and then incentivizing those properly and
highly is important, very important.
Rachel, you want to answer the same question?
What incentive strategies have you used in the past that have been the most effective,
whether financial, cultural, things that you do for your team that helps the bottom line?
Okay, so this is actually really fun.
We had a new training girl get, she was with us for six years and she became our trainer.
She looks like Sabrina Carpenter. She's like just every girl's Bessie.
And she came to me with a six-point plan for keeping our staff and making them happy.
Number one, she said was cards.
So me and Kelsey handwrite a card for every girl on their birthday and their anniversary with us.
It has gone so far. Oh, and we give them Vax Bucks, which they can spend in the studio on stuff.
Second thing was we made a self-care kit with a bunch of stuff that a girl needs at work.
Like gum and a lint roller and just like it's got these little cute pink toolboxes that we got off Amazon.
And she filled them full of so much stuff. I can send them to you, they're so cute.
She came with, you know, and then there is the money side of things which I would have to say we're decent at.
but we're really in 2026 are going to work on how we how we relate that to
them what they're really making because when you stop like give them commission
and give them you know sign up like if you sign up in EFT and you get $25 or
whatever you get and their tips like we can they are getting it but they're not
connected they still think they make 18 15 hour they're not connecting what they
made 30 so this year we're really gonna work on that reach out to them and make
sure they know exactly what they're making. But yeah, incentives. We had one manager that we
incentivized because I think, I've got a salon in another city and I don't want to go to Edmonton,
it's nothing cold. And it's three hours away and I got rock chips and I don't want to drive there.
So, but we were going through turnover. Like this girl was, she's amazing, she hustles, she's so
great. But I was like, why can't you keep your staff? Like what are you doing? So one of the
four things that I gave her was an incentive based on six months and the
year of her team staying we have only lost one since the last five girls that
we hired since we put that in so it wasn't just money and she gets money
based because she's very monetary motivated which if I can have a whole
spot of those would be so easy they're not all money just want money it's their
It's their love language, exactly.
Some of them just want that card.
Some of them, yeah, can do that.
Yeah, recognition, special gift.
Yeah, Lisa does this really well.
So I'd like to pass it over to Lisa.
I think everything that they've said is so true.
So when somebody starts with us,
they do get their little welcome gift to get them all set up.
They get their manual, they get their uniform,
you know, all that different stuff.
They're what is expected of them.
then right now we have 42 girls that work for us each one of them will go on
our platform and welcome them with their name so you know hi Bailey my name is
Wendy I'm so excited to work with you so they they get 41 messages back
welcoming them so I didn't realize the impact that that was making until they
They know how great that was and how much they shared with their parents.
They didn't even know that it was happening.
They haven't met any of these girls, and they already feel so welcomed.
Their room blows up.
Yeah, their room blows up all at once.
Yeah.
So that's really neat, especially when they're not expecting it.
So one of the girls who started, as soon as I've added them to the group chat,
somebody will recognize that it's not always me.
I like it better.
We used to be WhatsApp, but now we're using Connect.
Yeah, just as a bigger, just once you get to a certain number, it's hard to, you know, right?
So that's it. Then, I cannot say enough, it is finding out what their love language is.
So if you have five staff, that's easy. If you have ten staff, whatever it is.
I have staff that are very money motivated. They are by far the easiest to take care of.
So they would get a competitive wage, you know, my big girl managers can make a lot of money per hour, but then they also get their commissions definitely bigger when it comes to membership, lotions, things like that.
Then they get reward points. So reward points can be done with selling, but also if you came in for a shift.
so really what I did is took everything that my staff are doing that was driving
me crazy and put it into a positive so if you have a perfect month which means
you did not call in sick you did not change a shift you did not all the
things when it comes to showing up that we would just take for granted of course
you get a perfect month you get
You get reward points for coming in, staying late, bringing product from one store to another,
doing something good in the community on your anniversary.
And the girls get to buy things with it.
So, huge value if they're buying something Perfect 10 for 10 bucks.
They get more than double of that.
But they can buy watches, iPhones, a huge one this year was Dyson wraps.
I think I had to buy seven Dyson Airwraps, so TVs, computers, all that kind of stuff that gets updated every year, so that's good, and then we also have our membership contest every year, which is probably more in-charge based, like, because we'll have a manager and an in-charge on that cell, and then we'll have two bed cleaners on, so they, yeah, so they, they, we have a contest,
and we really found that doing it against themselves instead of each other so that changed
probably about 10 years ago so again they get uh you know three points for an all-access sign up
and then they get two points for an upgrade and then they get to buy things from that
i had one girl that doubled it so the biggest thing was like a you know i think it was a td
at 80 points and she did 160 points so I had to figure out how to do that. So what she wanted.
So that has been a really good one for us but also touched on that you know because I've had
stores, I've had girls that have been with me for 29 years, 27 years, that's what came back to us
is we've always done this incentive thing. They have car allowances and benefits and all that
kind of stuff but as the minimum wage went up what i was missing and their t4 was great you know
because of their bonus then they get a retention so they get a direct sun which is our membership
contest reward but then in this slower season if we do not dip then they all get bonus out at the
end of the year as well as a team they would that gets broken up and bonused out depending on how
many hours you were so the amount of money so that's all cash anyway so their t4 was good
but their hourly wage felt too close to the minimum wage was so when our minimum wage up
went to close to 18 and they were say making 26 and they were making that so close to what their
you know daughter made that was only a 10 difference i really had to change that so
So my last two years have focused on the hourly wage.
So now my big girls make $32 to $34 an hour because I listened and then I had to adjust to that.
So that was a big one that I just wasn't expecting because I knew what they cost me.
So that was a huge one that I would really pass on to them.
But the reward price is fantastic because even your brand new bed cleaner can get rewards for coming in, staying late, the perfect room, all of those things.
And I think that is huge as well. So you've got to have levels. And the biggest thing that young women want, if you have young women, is they want the connection.
Right? So my job, I work with them because I still work on the floor. I'm like, hey Casey, I haven't seen you in a while. Can you, you know, what's going on? So how's Sam? How's his school? Like I go right into her boyfriend, what she's interested in. We do not talk about work.
Now I spend that, we're working, but I spend that whole night focused on drilling with her with a ton of questions like I really want to catch up with her. So one more thing that I will say is when you've got a big group is you will forget somebody. If anyone here is a middle child or they have a middle child, there will always be the one that just gets missed.
so what I do is I have a list they do not need to know it's a list and we
call them strokes and I don't like it came from waitressing probably when I
was 17 or 18 years old and so I have to make sure to stroke them which is an
absolutely inappropriate word now so we're going to have to change that so now that I'm saying that I'll have to try it no so that's my way to keep myself accountable
that I haven't missed somebody that might be my middle child.
They haven't done anything super awesome, but they're still awesome,
and they haven't done anything super crappy,
because those two get all of the attention.
So I really make sure that my middle children get attention,
the ones that just are consistently great.
I love that.
So one thing on your takeaways, keep a list.
Another thing that you mentioned,
All these challenge fields, just because you've always done it that way doesn't mean that it's the right way for today.
If you have to adjust the way that you're paying your staff, do it.
Especially in this day and age.
I'm going to move over to Sally with a new question.
Sally, how do you handle long-term staff who are reliable but no longer hungry?
What systems or conversations have you used to reignite them?
Well, you fire them. No. This happens a lot, and you know what? It happens to me. So as owners, we get burned out. We get, like, tired of being in there. We get tired of doing the schedule and doing the payroll and sitting in the meetings and doing all that stuff.
so just imagine what they're going through as well and I think as leaders
of your team you need to lead them not tell them so I'm always about showing up
and like Lisa said how are you doing today what's going on what's happening
in your life because they may have something that's going on in their life
that's affecting what's going on in their job so there's always that aspect
We had a staff member, and to give it perspective, she was in Bradford and we were in Toronto.
So she lived in Bradford and every day she would drive to Toronto to our salon.
And I'm like, are you crazy?
And she goes, no, I just love the clients, I love everything about this.
So we gave her an incentive.
The longer she stayed with us, the more her wage would go up because we understood that she had gas, she had to pay.
And so that was super important for her.
And I think when they go into the lull, it's not because they don't want to be there.
It's because something is going on in their lives, and nine times out of ten, they're going to be female.
So it could also be what time of the month that would be, or their boyfriend's not talking to them and something has happened.
They have to feel comfortable coming to you and saying, I need help, or I'm going through this right now.
So being that leader and guiding them and having the structure around that they can have that safe place is super important.
And I think that then you don't get into that. You don't get into those ones that are just like not trying anymore.
Lisa's had people for 28 years and I applaud her. She does an amazing job.
Same with Rachel. She has great staff. I'm lucky to have a staff member for five years.
I want them to leave a better person when they started with me, when they leave.
I want them to go on to a career, because I'm not, I'm a little swan.
I'm not a big chain.
I don't have eight stores.
I don't have managers.
I don't have vice presidents.
It's me.
So I don't have the capability to promote them within, so I want to promote them without.
So I want to give you the skills so that you could be an amazing individual.
So that's really important when it comes to selling your skill set, right?
That's not money, right? That's culture that's looking at their opportunities for education,
and like she said, making them a better human when they arrive.
Now, I'm going to ask you the same question.
No, I'm going to finish.
It's so true. They need to lead better than they come.
Some make it harder than others.
But when I'm teaching them something, make sure they know that this isn't just for here.
Like, you know, I'm going to tell you something real, you learn this together.
But you are going to use this for the rest of your life.
That's huge value.
That is more than money.
But if you're being awesome, tell them.
You know, this isn't just about what you're going to learn today.
This you are going to use anywhere.
Right?
I know you're leaving me.
I know you're moving on.
But you're going to use that anywhere.
Make sure you tell them.
So I just wanted to end on that note.
First of all, you know, when you guys come to events like this, they would say if you can leave with one or two great ideas, then you've really accomplished something.
And I think Mike and I, being up here, have probably learned that, number one, don't stroke your staff.
And number two, do not bring up the time of the month.
At least as men, don't do that.
Do you have any ideas on how you can re-ignite your staff to re-energize them if you notice
that they have become complacent?
Yes, I think creating a feedback culture where feedback is consistent all the time is imperative.
If you leave behavior unaddressed for weeks at a time, or months at a time, you can expect
the behavior to get worse and harder to change. I use this analogy about a tree and the roots in a
tree and the roots are the behavior and any of us have planted a tree there's a root ball and
you dig this little hole you put the tree in that the hole you fill it up if you were to go move
that tree or pick up that tree two years later the root balls almost all attack and there's just a
few little roots growing through it. At that time you can move the tree no problem that's a behavior
that you can change with regular feedback if you leave that behavior to
go for a long time and the roots are deeper and you're trying to change the
behavior then egos come into play you kind of have that you're trying to
change me kind of thing and you're going to get a lot more pushback so highly
advised regular feedback and when an employee is struggling or they are there
maybe they're past their best before date maybe it is time for them to move
on you have an obligation to the employee to have that conversation
because either they can help your business grow or you can help them to
grow by moving on if they don't fit anymore then it's it's not it's not
unreasonable for them to have just reached a place where they would want to
move on so you have that conversation and then you also can say look if that's
where you're at let's just be candid go home and think about it and if we want
to devise it you've been with me for a long time and I'm super loyal to you but
if you want to devise a 90 to 100 day 120 day plan for us to help you move on
we're not letting you go today we love you we care for you so if you need references or a reference
letter we'll help you if that's what you like if not we just need the behavior to come back
to what it was what it was six months ago yeah it's hard having those uncomfortable conversations
that you guys are in position that you need uh rachel i'm gonna ask you the next question um
dress code how do you approach maybe a dress code in your salons uh what role does appearance play
in professionalism, branding, and client trust?
And how do you get your staff to buy into that?
Oh, they love uniforms.
Does anybody not do uniforms?
Like this?
Oh, you don't?
Okay.
So I'm going to go through what I experienced.
We didn't have uniforms for, like, the longest time.
And then I was working in the store,
and it's a lot to think about what you're going to wear to work.
And you walk into the store, and, like, the girls,
we ended up making our dress code
based on what we didn't want to see anymore.
and so I'll say my I do all of our onboarding so I sit for two hours it's
the only time I spend with the staff I spend two hours with them giving them
our core core values our culture and I look them all square in the eyes and I
say this I have a fierce vote you have to have your brought back shirt your
name tag every single shift your hair and makeup has to look like you are
going to have lunch with a girlfriend I don't need you done to the nines I
I don't need you in nightclub makeup, but you have to look like you care because you
can't sell and be confident if you don't feel that way, which our job is sales.
Like, you're not going to open conversations with every person if you don't feel great.
So, very fierce about that.
So, we have shirts that say bronzebacks on them.
They've got crop shirts, sweaters.
We say no cover-ups over our t-shirts.
We allow them to have one inch of midriff.
We have a lot of really cute girls.
and it looks cute when they wear like little biker shorts and they show off their tan i think
i took that from my general manager because she can do that and she's like the girls like it like
if they know that they're empowered to do that yes we have a ton of men who tan in our stores
and we don't have creeps and no matter where you go like our girls look nice but letting them have
that one-inch adventure was important no facial piercings we're in the beauty sales industry
We're fierce about that. If you change your color of hair, it might not work out for us anymore.
No mucklucks, no slippers, no Tasman, no sweatpant material.
I am fierce about it, and we are very direct about it, and you get written up pronto if it doesn't happen.
I do, one of our core values is trust, and so I do tell our girls,
you know I'm not swinging by on a Sunday at 2 to make sure your hair and makeup and you're not wearing mucklucks, and
that you look great. No flowy skirts, all those things.
And so it's a form of trust that they show up just like they showed up on time and just like they did all of our other core values, that they look that way.
I think it probably means a lot of fear on your staff as well.
If you look at the Ublux team today, they're all wearing the same sweater or t-shirt.
It takes the guesswork out of that uniform.
Getting dressed in the morning.
It makes it easier for them to come to work and go back to what they're wearing in the morning.
I like that.
We did have something that's come out recently is like when girls have departed, they will return their bronze back shirts. And so now we have a thrifting area where they can come in when they come into the head office and there's like a whole wall of like shirts that have been donated back by other backspace or ones that they've bought that they don't love anymore.
we do custom orders every two months where there's like different colors of
long-sleeve shirts racer bags t-shirts and they can choose their colors within
it so all of a sudden you'll see Michaela she'll show up in maybe and the
girls like coming up looks so good I'm gonna get that one so yeah they have
They have movement within it, which is fine.
Great question.
So you make them buy their uniforms?
Yes, they have something with them.
And they come off their paycheck,
or they can use their back spots.
Yeah.
Isn't there a minimum quantity,
like if one person wanted to, you don't have to order?
No.
Not anymore.
We use a company called Blaze Apparel.
They're in Calgary, I'm sure she would ship to you.
And she gives us, we took a photo of one of our staff
in all the tops. There's a t-shirt, racerback, crop t-shirt, crewneck sweater. We even have crop hoodies and they're super cute.
And then you could buy one size of one color, whatever. It's just in the minimum quantities of how many logos you apply, you get cheaper.
So once you get over 10, 20, 50. So that's why we do a custom order every bit. And then we stock a certain amount of just black t-shirts, black crewnecks.
So you don't manage their pants, you only make them buy their shirts?
Yes, let's talk about pants.
Let's talk about bottoms.
My bottoms are my issues. I supply the shirts, I pay for them, I pay for them.
Are they like in cat hair and other things?
I pay for them all, I launder them all, I keep them all at the spawn.
I want to work there.
I do everything on their upper, I allow them their bottoms, and I give them a mandate that I don't supply their bottoms.
So I gave them an example, a very clear example of what I want to see.
And I'm very honest in onboarding.
When I'm like, girls, you're putting on 10,000 steps in a shift.
You should be wearing athleisure.
So biker shorts are Bax Babe's best friend.
That's what I say, number one.
You can get them on Amazon.
There's so many good Lulu dupes.
And then you show up, you're 10, you look super cute.
Athletic bottoms are number one.
where I have a photo of my girls in it
and I'm like, this is what you should look like.
We say no distressed denim,
nothing dirty, no cat hair,
no flowy skirts,
no short skirts.
We haven't had an issue, so I haven't
had to mandate them yet. I love the scrubs
idea. I think it's super cool.
Might play with it a little bit this year
because I've just never opened that.
Like, what we're doing now works
really well. But maybe
what I did is I gave a very
very clear example in our own wording of what they should look like.
Lisa, you want to add to that quick?
We're quick.
Okay, I will be really quick.
I will be really quick.
So when we decided to go uniforms
years and years and years ago,
like 20 years ago, we went
very covered up. We just decided
I was missing out
on 50% of the population
because I needed
that middle-aged woman, which is me now, but I was 20 when I started, to feel really comfortable
bringing in her husband when maybe she wasn't feeling the best of herself. So we went to
a very strict uniform, which was like a scrubs. So then about 10 years ago, the girls just
begged for me to lighten it up a little bit. So now my girls get, I'm not nearly as nice
is Rachel, and she's awesome, and her girls do look fantastic, but mine is a very, they
get a uniform for me, so it's a Lululemon skirt that has little shorts underneath, so
they get like a tennis skirt, they have one particular top that they can wear, they have
to wear their name tag, can't wear anything over it, just for the first time, they got
a crew neck that says wellness, that they can wear with their skirts, but that's it,
and I absolutely control everything about it.
And they love it.
I bought as set of scrubs for every single person to try on
and I let the managers decide on what they wanted to wear.
We've just put it off for this year
because they still love,
they were getting too hot and sweaty in it.
So they wanted to stick with their Lululemon and shirts
and I needed them to all be the same.
So we couldn't use some scrubs, some uniforms, like some boots, so we just have put it to the side for now.
But I love it.
So, yeah.
Just a quick question for you.
What is the normal cover role of the skirt?
How do you do that?
That's a great question.
So we haven't had it yet, but I ask them every time because the skirt is kind of long enough and it does have, you know, a little covering.
it's more the shirt that not one person and I have all ages and all sizes that
have not felt comfortable in this particular skirt that I bought we did
have a couple girls that did not fit the shirt with the Swift tech that they
found that was just a little bit more fitting so absolutely I have an
alternative to that. That's important right? Very, very important, so, but, yeah, yeah, so.
You went with men, 48 staff in the morning. No, Murph. Oh Murph, Murph. But we don't make him
pretty sure. Murph looks amazing in a t-shirt.
Yeah, that is the reason I'm looking at scrubs to do that. I had a problem with the bottoms
because I do have girls of all ages and all sizes was mine was about the tights
being see-through. I was a little bit worried about that and mine, whoever
mentioned it, mine was about cat hair and dog hair. Like I just can't, yeah.
We'll pass the mic over to Mike. Mike, how do you know, how did you know it was the right time to expand and 100% of your focus on this industry?
Was there a defining moment? Was there a metric or a volume shift that kind of told you, yeah, this is what I'm going to do on the franchise side, on the store side, as well as the equipment side?
What do you think of both of those scenarios?
So I think everybody in this room knows that the panic has been stagnant and diminished over the last few years, to say the least.
Forget about COVID.
bit so we're operating with the same pool and we need to try to get more
revenue or increase our revenue per client we need to increase it so that's
that's really what we started looking at those numbers we realized the tanning
the bottom end is not getting fed and so we've got some of these tanners that are
just gonna start to age out eventually so we need to feed the body through
through wellness, through the red light, the cocoon,
the vitality bed, all of those beds,
we need to add to the services,
because we're only accepting the clients.
And now we've done it in a way
that we've got clients coming in
that don't necessarily go for a tan,
go come in and do the cocoon, do the red light.
They would have never walked into a traditional tanning,
so on, ever.
So now that we've done that,
I think it's a big part of our revenue.
So that's we've increased revenue that we've never seen by having those services
Okay, so
people and you know you're putting parts together and things like that I feel
like owning a tanning salon is being so creative you get to make your specials
every month or every two weeks you get to decide you know how just there's just
so much creativity so I think that feeds me every day I cannot imagine being in
another industry at all I am obsessed with tanning I don't feel like when
when everyone says, like, oh, I feel like tanning is on the down,
I was the one last year being like,
is everyone seeing how much Gen Zers are talking about tanning?
Like, tanning's popping off.
I think that consumers are consumered out a bit right now,
and now they're coming into the salon and being like,
what's this tanning bed all about?
Like, I know I've been told it's bad, but these look fucking cool,
and, like, you girls all look great.
Like, I think I'm tanning curious now.
So I'm like super into my tanning right now. I think it's so badass all the new equipment that's coming out.
I am so excited. I am right now getting decided on getting an Element or a K11 Air and that's just so fun.
Sorry for my mouth but Tony Robbins says it cuts through people's subconscious when you swear so I will swear when I swear.
I think that 2026 was the best year for product launches. I bought 400 bottles of Dermadark spray.
I brought all of Canada's Dermadark sprays, sorry y'all, but I can sell that in any room
possible.
I think it is so, like, wellness all day, guys, I love it, I've got it all in my stores,
I've got saunas, I can talk about the balance of products I don't put in the face, full
spectrum, infrared, how it mentally affects you, hydration stations, every single person
should have two.
Like, mad love for wellness, but when you do your profit margins on products that get
get sold with tanning I'm sorry no other industry has that like I buy products
that complement my wellness that I get to mark up a hundred percent I don't get
to mark them up as much as I get to because I have a co-op from you blocks
like I'm sorry but everything is dragging us away from tanning but when
you look back at tanning you're like shit is awesome and like I have so many people
come from Montreal and when they stop in and they're like yeah give me the max
drop in, they pay cash, they want, they don't care how much a sample of Starlet is, and, like, that is, the tithing industry done well is extremely profitable, like, I have a fractional CFO, which, if anyone doesn't do that, please do that, basically, he's a CFO for six companies, and he's my CFO, and he said, Rachel, I have never in my life seen more profitable business than this one, your profit percent is so high,
Have you heard of me?
Oh yeah, Kenny would do that all day.
But yeah, Kenny, love it.
The next two questions are for
Doug and Sally
and then I have one final question for all of the panelists
before we wrap up.
Doug, you're managing a lot of people
and a lot of information
and in the last year
I've had the privilege to work with your team
and they are a fine run machine
I'm going to give a shout out to Tracy because I think it's a lot of work.
I'll give a shout out to Tracy.
And just for the record, I don't exist up here without her doing all the work.
How do you view training? As a cost or as a revenue driver?
Can you give me an example where better training directly increases sales or your retention?
Oh, it's not a cost. Training is...
If you just think about the biggest brands in the world and how your customer experience
is with those brands, call it Starbucks or Home Depot or two of my favorites.
GNC is another one where it doesn't matter.
The person behind the desk can be 1% body fat or 40% body fat, but you go in and ask
them a question.
I'm older, so I'm looking at my home.
My joints are bothering me.
What do you got?
They know everything about every product in there, and that is just constant training.
Home Depot, same thing.
Everybody knows where everything is in every single aisle.
You can walk up to anybody and say, where do I find you?
So that's how 15 go down halfway down and that doesn't come from one time on training isn't just onboarding just one time
It is non-stop and we manage those guys. We're fortunate enough to develop their own software
Performance dashboard employee logs in to start their day shows where they rank KPI wise on in the region in the country
So all our franchisees also have the same thing
So it's very easy to have conversations because they're set up with the data long before you have the conversation
So it manages that process. Early on, everything was papered. The advantage of having a point-of-sale system that could deliver that kind of data for you to decide what needed to be trained, it was so awesome when we got to the place where the data told us where we had to focus.
and then so I just say start with your numbers every single day know where
those KPIs are they tell you where to train I use this analogy with spinning
plates like the circus performers let's say you've got five key KPIs in your business
one plate will always be wobbling if not two and so when those plates are
wobbling that's where you go and train and when you start training there that
plate will start spinning inevitable embrace the fact I know we all say it my
my God, how many times do I have to tell them?
All the time.
So when that plate starts wobbling back here,
that just tells you you gotta go train on that KPI.
Yeah.
Okay, cool then.
I have a question.
What do you think is more about you generally,
and can you give us an example
of better training directly in cruiser sails?
I am a proponent of definitely training,
but not what you think.
I think we need to start training our individuals that are operating the counter as influencers.
They are an influencer for your brand.
They are not a salesperson.
They're not a consultant.
They are influencing that client's decision to choose you or choose certain things.
So it's more talking to them on that type of level versus having these strict structures and sales goals and all this other thing.
I always say to them who would you sell this to? Who would you talk to? Your best friend?
How would you talk to them? Because how I say it is different than how Lisa, Rachel, Mike and Doug would all say it differently.
So how would you say it where you're coming across? So you've got to give them the foundational skills and then let them fly.
What I think we do too much in this industry is we verbiage everything. We verbiage the heck out of it.
I don't know anyone that knows what breezy sunset smells like, but I don't know what that smells like, right?
We have to bring it down to their level, and their level is TikTok, and it's a 30-second video.
That's how much time you have.
You have to influence that client to purchase us as their product and anything above that.
The next scroll is what you want to achieve.
That's your add-on sales for your client, right?
So when you're training, make sure you have your standard operating procedures.
These are the non-negotiables.
So what we were talking about, the lower half of the uniform.
This is a non-negotiable.
This is how you need to look.
If this is not how you're looking, then let's see how we can get you there.
Like with a couple of my staff, they couldn't afford it.
And that was a conversation.
So now I obviously went out and I got them Lululemon gift cards.
I gave them Lululemon gift cards so they could go get pants.
right so have those conversations with them and they are an influence of your
brand so train them that way and the way you train them that way it's not the
whole way we used to bring them right it's changing it's evolving it's using
AI and all those things to come up with scripts and different things for them so
that they have the tools in their toolbox to pull out but they can choose
which tool to use right I love one thing that she said at the beginning I want
I want you guys to go back to your salon
and look at all of these cubes that you have on your shelf
and I want you to ask your staff,
out of all of these cubes,
I want you to give me at least one or two clients
that would buy that product.
Instead of telling me what's in that product,
I want to know one or two clients
that would buy those products.
Start at the back, break your way forward.
Love that, that was great.
Okay, next question for all of our panelists.
So Lisa, we'll start with you.
What's one uncomfortable but necessary move every salon owner should consider making in the next 12 months to stay relevant and profitable?
Well, I think everybody's going to say if you don't have memberships, that's the first thing you need to do.
Memberships are absolutely the way you have to go, and you can always bring in wellness for that membership.
So the uncomfortableness is spending money, right?
But I think we would all say that.
I think for me and being inspired by this panel,
I think the most uncomfortable would be is encouraging your C group,
you know, you've got your A team, your B team, your C team,
that maybe their life is done.
So that's my most uncomfortable.
I think the important thing that I've learned in the last year or so is looking inward by
yourself and being able to take accountability and look at the direction that you are going.
Use software and AI to be your friend and kill your enemies.
We were talking last night about, we, I went online and I put in, please tell me what panels
want to use in this location, what would be your location, and do a full analysis on my
competitors and tell me where their gaps are and where I can pick up on that.
So there's things that you can do and things that you can be doing that makes your life
easier.
Ask your staff, what's the hardest part of your job today?
And my staff was, the phones don't stop ringing.
They don't stop ringing, okay?
Okay, so we got online booking.
What else?
They still ring for certain people.
Okay, so now we're putting in an AI chatbot
that when they call into our salon,
it's gonna send them a text message to book an appointment.
Right?
Find out where they are missing their spots
and make it easier for them, right?
We're always constantly trying to figure out for the client,
but we also have to make it easier for our staff
to help that client.
And so as owners, we have to look inward on our processes.
Make sure you have a manual
and standard operating procedures on everything that you deal with. We have a robbery kit that's in the drawer that if they ever got robbed they pull it out and they follow the checklist.
Hold on a second. Yeah, hold on. I need to follow the checklist. Or there's a power outage. There needs to be, this is what you do in a power outage.
Because that's, those are the things that you get. You get those phone calls and you're like, oh my god, have they done this?
But if you have procedures in place, and you've looked inward at where your gaps are, that'll get fixed.
Right? You have to fix that. That's your job. Their job is to do theirs.
So SOPs, right? A lot of SOPs.
So I think we've done a lot of talking about staff and motivating them.
And the hardest thing as entrepreneurs is we get burnt out, and we get exhausted,
and we're tired of the shit with the staff and the shit with the customers.
So that's the biggest thing that I think we all need to work on is making sure that we take care of ourselves, keep ourselves hungry and interested in this business because it's a great business. And to Doug's point, I think it was Doug's point, is there's no business with margins like what we have. So you're not going to find another business where you can make this kind of money.
So make sure that you're motivated, and then you'll find that people will follow that energy, including your front staff.
If you're burnt out, and your front staff sees that you're burnt out, they are your front line.
It doesn't matter what you do, wellness, panning, it's all out the window.
That person behind the desk is unmotivated and not doing anything, so just try to motivate yourself, that's all.
And then, obviously, you need to invest in the business.
so even if you take less
and you invest whether it's UV equipment
if you're not at the park or some other wellness
and you just start, that will get your
EFTs up, we have EFTs at
400 bucks in our place
we have some EFTs that are
$300, $400 a month
quite a few people put them in
the money will follow if you just
ok so your question was
what uncomfortable thing
should you do in 2026
I don't know if anyone else does this
in this room but
this is an uncomfortable thing that we did a few years ago and I wish I always
said if I had a microphone to a room full of tax on people this is what I would
say is do not let any other lotion other than what you sell be used in your
stores I do it it is a non-negotiable it was the easiest thing I did never
looking back yes all right so you can smell it and you know and you can tell
on the thing but we don't say no you can't use any of our equipment and you
They say, you can absolutely use that.
Understand those.
Because it's not going on my acrylics.
And, you know, once you get people on your side with the why,
which is it protects my equipment, I don't know what's in that bottle.
Once you get them on your side, then it makes sense.
They get it.
Like, that's a $90,000 tiny bed.
And I don't know where your product is from.
But also, I really care about your skin and what you're using.
Like, let's talk about what you're using.
No, if you bought it, I don't care if you came in with a bottle of Reveal that you bought from Sally.
I'll think about it, but you can use it in my stand-up, because I don't know where it's from.
It's got a Brownsback sticker on the back. I know it was bought from U-Blocks, and I know it's safe for my equipment.
But also, our lotion mix was chosen for our climate and our equipment.
so when we say that to our guests to be like we've chosen what is right for us
and for you let's find the right one for you as long as they come through to the
why then I will say this is the first experience that we've had with non
lotion users and we've had to do a full court press on that I'll keep you posted
how it goes but it is I just it breaks my heart because what's happening is
the people come in with these random ass bottles of product and be like my other
salon let me do it and I'm like yeah we gotta train the whole tanning salon industry that you
want to use my vets the product has to be bought from me because then we like I see a lot of people
complaining about diversion and online stuff and I'm like you're letting that happen to you. Rachel
I'm going to do my hardest to make sure that this message is transferred to salon owners. Can I make a
comment to that? Just talk to your uva labs rock they'll put some free samples in and for those
Just give them one of those, and let them use your lay down, and make them leave their bottle at the front desk, they'll love you forever.
Yeah, they have to keep it at the front.
That's what I do, I make them leave their bottle, I give them one of those samples, they go on the lay down,
because they'll fight it on the stand up, then they'll buy a bottle the next time.
You guys are going to get a lot of samples in the UK.
Dan, you're up.
If I had a recommendation about doing something uncomfortable, it would be to have,
do a serious evaluation of every one of your team members and really make sure
that they're all team members that want to be on the bus and if they're not have
those tough conversations to either improve their performance to the
standards that you want them to be or help them move on to the next career
tongue-in-cheek I say help them move on to ruin somebody else's business but
you gotta you gotta really look at all of them we become very complacent let
anybody stand behind the desk because oh it's Friday night I don't want to
work so i'm just gonna let this person fill my shift it's not how you're gonna have successful
business so have those tough conversations evaluate all your team members and decide
whether they are on the bus that you're that you want to drive one thing to mention there
too the job market has changed you're not going to list a job and recruit the best person on
indeed or whatever platform facebook jobs right your job in your community is to get out there
and get to know people when you're going out for dinner and introduce yourself.
Your job as salon owners to recruit new staff is to build your bench.
And Nick does that very, very well.
In our community, he will go out there and network himself.
If somebody says to me, hey, I'm giving you my notice,
Nick's got four people on the bench waiting for me.
The other thing that's important too is advertise your culture.
When you look at your socials and things like that,
You want people in your community to want to work there, right?
When you look at our socials, I've got friends and community members that are like,
Oh my God, your job is so fun.
It's like, well, talk to me on a Sunday morning, right?
Is that what nips in town?
We do that on purpose, not only for you guys, but I do it because my job is also recruiting staff, right?
So if I want a bench, it's a hell of a lot easier than leaving behind dry and quickly just filling that hole.
I don't want to do that. I want to make sure that I have that bench set up.
If you guys are in a restaurant, you have a really positive experience with somebody, my favorite line is,
Hey, you obviously love your job, and you're really, really good at it. If you ever want to take me, call me.
So it's a compliment. It's easy enough. There are energy. But say, I would hire you in a nanosecond.
And I'm always hiring.
My line is, I'm always hiring.
If not for me, for my friends, right?
Being like, listen, you're not right for me,
but I'll find you a job, because you're not supposed to.
Go ahead.
My son now wants to serve as a team employee.
She was so, like, amazing at customer service.
I said, when you turn 18,
I overlapped and he can't qualify with me,
because she was amazing.
That's awesome.
I would say according to the team that you was,
So, you can do what I found on the screen.
No.
Exactly.
You're just such a cool person with such an awesome soul.
I can teach you Scandic.
Yes.
We can do that.
Right?
I can't teach you that to be a cool human.
Yes.
That's my service.
Right?
Can I point out something that we noticed the other day on Mike's Instagram for California
Sun, is that where you have your link for your website on his Instagram, if you open
up california sun's instagram for the link for his business it is either the link for his business
website or to join his team oh i like that that is spectacular because that is where our employees
are they're on instagram so i just had to say that was something i'm going to do like a second thing
okay so we're going to wrap things up our panelists are here all day if you guys get
If you have a chance to chat with them in the hallway or at a trade show, please do so.
I want to give them all a round of applause.
Thank you.